[Music]
so I'm Matt Baldwin
I'm the director of cloud native
engineering here at net up and I'm here
today to talk to you about NetApp's
cloud data services strategy and how
we're trying to simplify enterprise
multi cloud deployments of cloud native
infrastructure and cloud native workload
we build this on top of six different
pillars that we've defined in our
product which is the first is how do we
simplify enterprise multi-cloud
kubernetes and what we mean by that is
what we're trying to arrive at is that
you do not have to worry about the cloud
provider that you're building your
cluster on top of that your manage your
infrastructure on top of that the
experience matches the same so if you're
using Google that experience is the same
as Amazon as is the same for on-premise
and that's what we're trying to do with
our enterprise multi-cloud kubernetes
offering our second pillar is
application management and we're trying
to follow the same theme there which is
to how do you simplify the developer
experience with building shipping and
running applications inside of
kubernetes how do you ensure those
applications can scale how do you
automate that how do you scale them
across multiple providers how do you
scaled them from on Krim to off prim in
a hybrid scenario and that is what we're
driving out with application management
essentially how do you transform a
kubernetes cluster into Heroku like
experience for the developer so they
never have to understand companies they
don't need to know what his do is they
can perform a canary not a problem the
third component that we stand on top of
is managed data services in storage so
net app is a storage company as many
people know and we have over 20 years of
experience in enterprise grade storage
and delivering solutions out to
consumers and customers and what we're
doing is we're working to lift all those
features into and pull those into
kubernetes so that we can guarantee your
application we can protect it we can
guarantee I ops for your app we can move
your app around from provider to
provider and the storage will follow you
snapshot mere clone all that goodness
comes from the net app technology that
we're pulling up into kubernetes and
that's one of the main one of the
primary pillars that we're standing on
top of is that we were able to we've
solved the stateful work load problem in
kubernetes adding it up
and that's very important as you guys
probably all know for kubernetes the
fourth pillar is ecosystem integration
what we mean there is we don't mean just
taking helm charts and throwing them
into a bucket of a marketplace and then
letting the user figure out what they
need to do with that when we're talking
you go system integration we're talking
about deeply integrating with ecosystem
partners to deliver a value out to their
users versus being a feature farm we're
trying to just iterate through as many
features as possible what we're trying
to do is arrive at user value so when
that user clicks that button slides that
slider enables that feature that they
immediately have value that they can
consume and we have a partner that we're
gonna bring on stage here in a bit to
talk about that that type of ecosystem
integration the fifth item is again
we're trying to build simple tooling for
developers operators and sres as our srt
are as our sre teams figure out and
solve issues we're pushing that that
type of those feature sets those types
of dashboards down to the end-user so
those users can use those things the
sixth pillar for us is channel partners
so our product actually enables you to
rebrand your case anyone can launch
their own kubernetes service we can
partner with anyone we have a partner
we're bringing onstage again who will
show you one of the partnerships that
we're doing on that but it allows us to
enable our enterprise partners to sell
to their enterprises and enable that
through the channel so we not only go
direct we also go through the channel
and that's one of the one of the big
pillars that we stand on top of so why
are we here today so we have four things
that we're gonna announce first that
we're working with NVIDIA Nvidia net up
are working together to deliver an
Nvidia kubernetes services product that
focuses on deep learning AI ml and I
have a ttle holic will be coming on
stage to talk about that the second item
is our cloud native application
management is going to go to pre-release
and that's going to be a bulk of this
presentation we're gonna show you what
that is and I'm gonna have Dan Norris
one of my senior engineers will come on
stage to demo that and take you through
all that work and again our focus is to
Bennett has always been to simplify the
experience for the user and I think
that's going to come
through when you start to see the
tooling that we've built for developers
like the third item is we've enabled an
in what we call an NPS enterprise
registry which is built on top of we've
added we've effectively integrated into
the CNC f Harbor project to enable
enterprise registry in public cloud and
private cloud as well and that's all
wrapped up inside of our workflow the
fourth item is clouds volume services on
GCP and that we're going to be going
into beta with that at the end of May
and because storage is rather important
to applications and so we're gonna
conclude today's presentation with a
discussion around cloud natives
persistent storage and how that relates
to to what we're doing and I have aleem
coming on to do that so first I want to
bring up adil will talk about our Nvidia
partnership on kubernetes thanks Matt
good morning everyone my name is a de
loja Lac I'm director of product
management over Nvidia I like that for
NGC so real quick what is NGC NGC is an
accelerated software hub some of the
most popular accelerated applications
out there in the marketplace we start
off with HPC and visualization but
naturally that bleeds over into ml and
DL which is a huge focus of ours so
start off as a container registry but we
expand it to a lot more than that since
we've since introduced pre train models
that are domain-specific across medical
imaging or video analytics also some
models that are up there just ready for
inference we've also introduced model
training strips so teaching entities how
to train at the state-of-the-art
accuracy and get models how to converse
sated with our accuracy from scratch
right so tell you exactly what container
to pull where to get your data sets what
learning rate does set and be able to
replicate some of those Acuras that we
drive and again growing above and beyond
that where we really start deriving
value is when you become domain-specific
right industry-specific so as Matt
alluded to earlier we are introducing
industry specific home charts or
workflows that frankly go from an
end-to-end perspective but why are we
here right we realized that that wasn't
enough right now I love this theme that
Matt's been driving which is
simplification
right this is a software hub you know if
it's almost giblets
the reality is data science is a team
sport right and often we talk about the
data scientist we talk about the
developers but it takes an array of
different personas collaborating
together to realize in the RAI of value
right wouldn't even talk about DevOps
systems admin IT managers who have to
worry about auto scaling will have to
worry about os's that are supported in
their data centers or in their
respective clouds so how do we alleviate
some of those those concerns and this is
why we're partnering with Nvidia that
would Sydney wouldn't a tap on the nks
service so real quick let me show you
let me show what NGC is all about as I
said earlier containers across an array
of different industries and segments to
come the deep learning here you know our
engineers our data scientists optimize
against our GPU accelerations optimized
tensor flow we upstream those to the
community to the open source community
as well but we also post those on NGS
containers on a monthly basis as I said
earlier we got pre-trained models across
an array of couple different industries
and some that are already ready for
inference and these model scripts that I
talked about again really showing you
how to reach state of their accuracy get
your models to converge and be able to
build on that but as I said earlier
that's not enough right how do we go
from use case it's actually being able
to deploy a prototype and so what we're
introducing and we're gonna be showing
later on at the booth on the demo is if
you go back to the slides please
is the ability to deploy a container or
a helm trout directly through the NGC
portal through the net cat through the
net app kubernetes service right so as a
data scientists or an ml doesn't matter
what your proficiency level is right to
be able to deploy with a few clicks onto
a favorite cloud service provider rather
on-prem seamlessly with just a few
clicks and we're just starting with
inferencing interest is the first use
case and that's the one we're going to
be demoing over at the booth at new
right again with just a few clicks to be
able to to deploy on a kubernetes based
cluster Auto scale up and down and as
many nodes as possible our inference
server right which can concurrently run
multiple models on a single GPU or on a
single node and we're starting with
inferencing because we think that that's
derives value right this whole notion is
about simplifying so you guys can derive
value but we want to get your feedback
we want to CRO create with you guys
right in this oddities tell us is that
deep learning training workflows that
you want us to focus on is it something
specific to machine learning and our
rapid libraries so we're super excited
this is just a start of what we're
kicking off and again we want to
co-create with the audiences we want to
derive value as opposed to just
providing shelves of software so we look
forward to hearing from you guys as we
go along in terms of what are some of
the use case you want to see but more
and more importantly we hope to see at
our booth later on at noon where we're
gonna be executing mantan demo on this
so without a further ado let me
introduce Dan sorry I we have five
speakers I wasn't sure who the next one
is let me introduce then real quick on
the stage who's gonna talk about app
management
turns out I don't actually need that hey
everybody so I'm pretty excited to share
with you what we've been working on to
kind of improve the foundation that
we've had with and chaos so what we have
been pretty good at is delivering
kubernetes like a consistent experience
across multiple clouds and what we've
been working on I mean my team is
basically the suite of features that we
think of as application management so
our goal here is to give you kubernetes
clusters that are batteries included so
to make the developer experience best
and breed of any product out there so
what we've been focusing on are things
like providing a git based workflow so
basically do a git push sort of workflow
to be able to actually create career
Nettie's deployments automatically to be
able to detect what type of application
you're actually delivering and we've
also been looking at shipping
application health dashboards metrics
logging pretty much everything that you
would want as an SRE while actually
going through and delivering value for
your product and we're not really
standing in the way here right these are
all sort of opt-in editions we're
implementing them as kubernetes customer
resources so these are things that we
are pre installing on your cluster ready
to go whenever you spin up a kubernetes
cluster on nks and so things that we're
adding on here to click auto-scaling
resource management quota configuration
and we've got a number of different
solution types and I'll walk through
sort of what that looks like as we get a
little bit into the demo so we're going
to see is sort of our take on what we
think application management should look
like so the way that we think of it is
that applications we deploy them into
projects if you're familiar with
kubernetes terminology a project is
basically an abstraction around
kubernetes namespaces we add a little
bit of magic on top of it again through
using custom resources and then what we
call solutions are basically definitions
of how you deploy your application it's
not just a deployment a stateful set a
daemon set right this adds context this
adds value by showing how you actually
deliver your application how it gets to
your cluster
um so a little bit more about projects
we think of it as a container right you
want to take everything that comprises
your application so perfect example is
say WordPress right you're gonna need
MySQL server you're gonna need the
WordPress PHP and all the other pages go
to that that belongs into all in the
same project those might be multiple
pods you can scale them differently
doesn't really matter because it's
Dahlgren IDs at the end of the day what
we add on top of that is again
extensions to namespace so we hook into
through our product our back so we're
effectively reflect that into the
clusters so that you as a cluster admin
can take that under strict who has
access to these particular resources so
say your SRE team is allowed to make
changes to your production applications
but your developers are only allowed to
read them right that's what we've kind
of added on as an extension there and so
in terms of the solutions that we've
come up with we kind of targeted three
for our pre-release so we have what we
call the tracker and the tracker is kind
of like the lowest common denominator of
our solution it's basically you were an
experienced kubernetes developer you're
experienced at actually delivering
applications and off the platform this
is how you effectively inform our
back-end of what that is so we can
effectively adopt your application as is
to keep your deploy strategy and it just
works again if you're familiar with
kubernetes terminology this is
effectively just label selectors we use
that to kind of adopt an existing of
deployment and adopt a existing stateful
set and that way you just manage it
through our interface and then the next
solution that we have is the git
workflow so effectively git push and KS
master we want to be able to take pretty
much any application that you have in
any programming language and make it
that simple to deploy and get a
kubernetes deployment out of it and the
third that we've got our helm charts
right at CN CF you know going pretty
hard on actually having helm charts be
sort of the package management solution
for a kubernetes so we want to support
that so all we really need to know is
where does your turret live and what
changes do you want to make to its
values yeah Mille which is how you
configure it and we effectively take
care of the rest we deploy it we manage
the lifecycle and we do this actually
again I've kind of familiar with the way
that kind of works
it's a client-server application so we
do it without the server component
because we've written custom code and
extensions on top of your kubernetes
cluster we're able to actually lock that
down and giving you a much more secure
way to actually deliver helm charts on
so now for the demo we're gonna do this
lives you'll see how this goes
apologize where is there we go so let me
just get to screen so bouncing around
sorry so what we have is basically a
multi cloud solution for deploying
kubernetes clusters so what I have here
I have two different clusters that are
deployed on GCP all the random names by
the way I didn't make any of these up so
spring browse and young forest they're
formers a three node cluster the ladder
is a seven node cluster all in the US
West one we've got an AWS cluster and
we've got a Azure cluster as well and so
in each of these clusters we pre
configure a enterprise registry so this
registry because it's based on hardware
allows us to manage both docker images
for your projects and also helm charts
so we'll go to young forests and see
what's on here and so I've went ahead
and pushed a number of images here we've
got Alpine and we've got Cassandra I've
got a boon to and then we've got a
couple helm charts and we can we can go
through and we can see and subdivide by
class right so we've got a couple of
charts here envoy and Prometheus we've
got a registry token that we use for
authentication and show that this
actually works we're going to retag next
latest if I could type
so this is just the upstream nginx image
I'm just gonna push it straight to the
cluster
and here we go so this is just pushing
the image straight up the cluster it
should show up as soon as this is done
thank you consequence Wi-Fi for
cooperating we have to refresh the page
I'm impatient sorry uh so not sure why
didn't pop up okay
welcome to the Chokey of doing live
demos so that's our enterprise registry
offering and so the other concept I
wanted to introduce you to is the
project concept so projects effectively
you have n number of clusters clusters
have n number of projects that your
projects or your applications live so we
have a number of different projects sort
of deployed on here and if I expand them
this is an example of one actually I'll
do the one on GCP there's an example of
one that's running on one of our GC p
clusters it tells you the cluster where
it's running we can download the cube
config straight here and so in this case
we've got a relatively simple app and a
couple other of ancillary solutions that
are running so we've got to go back end
supported by node.js front end all
running effectively on our get solution
you can tell that because of the branch
names that happened to be in the
solutions here in the service names and
then we've got an open EPS package which
is actually an install from a Helton
chart that we've reconfigured so now
I'll walk you through what adding a
project looks like so I'll click on this
add project and because I'm super clever
we're gonna call this Google next demo
and we will make put it on this young
forest cluster and the default workspace
so if you're familiar with namespace
quotas this is effectively what this is
exposing right now so you as a sre
managing this or a cluster admin can
actually set quotas on the amount of
resources that you use per project so
that way any container or any
application deployed into any of these
projects can be restricted by how much
CPU and memory that it uses so you don't
end up having one project taking over
your entire cluster so I'm not gonna
send any of that
I'm just gonna hit next and then you
have the ability to configure different
teams roles permissions when I use the
default here so that brings us to the
kind of the project overview screen
where we are able to actually deploy
solutions now so walk you through sort
of what that ends up looking like so
I'll start off with we've got again the
three different solution types available
we've got our Halton charts on the Left
we've got our applications or get push
workflow in the middle and then our
tracker which is sort of the adopt your
existing workload functionality so I'll
start off with the git workflow here and
we will call this hello next we need to
find an update strategy because this is
largely going to be a crew Breanna DS
deployment so that gives us the ability
to go through and determine kind of how
we want this to roll out when we do
updates
we can auto scale I'm not going to do
that because it's a pretty simple app so
that will create our application where
where does that go
this is doing
there we go cool so don't know what that
was about
anyway so because this is we're doing a
git workflow here we actually pre
install a git server so any updates that
go to that git server will actually
we'll get an event and we'll be able to
spin up a container and do a whole build
process for that so I have over here a
fairly basic but kind of hype
application it is a node.js application
that's actually using rust and
webassembly in the backend so I'm gonna
go ahead and add a new remote which will
let me push up to my cluster do that and
then I will go push this to the master
branch in this get repository and so
what we've seen is that this actually
has pushed up updates to this get server
and what is done is this actually
triggered a pipeline so we pre install
Tecton CD pipelines which is an open
source project that's basically
providing workflow abstractions on top
of kubernetes so what this is done is
actually triggered a build of creating
the docker container creating the the
deployment and doing the whole build
process managing all that for you so to
see that in action
we can see that we have one pod that's
spun up and it has a couple of minute
containers because that's how checked on
CD pipelines work so this is going ahead
and that's actually building the
container it's pushing it to the
registry and then it's going to create a
deployment so while that's doing that
I'm going to show you what installing a
helm solution looks like so we'll go
back to our main screen I'll add
solution I'll add a new package and one
of the things that we provide here is a
set of pre-baked effectively helmet
charts that we've gone through we vetted
that we no end up working on our systems
so I'll just install Redis you have the
ability within the system so I'm just
going to I'll rename it to Redis you
have the ability to actually go through
and edit the values camel here so in
case you wanted to customize the deploy
you can do that straight in the browser
before you actually deploy the
application so I'm just gonna go ahead
and create it and what you get is the
package information that comes straight
from the helm chart so that's all
basically part of the package that is
uploaded wherever it happens to be and
going back to our terminal you can see
what this is done is this actually
created a rightist slave and a Redis
master so we have kind of a highly
available solution here and so that's
just sort of creating in the background
and I just in the deploy process so the
third solution type that we have go back
to add solution is our tracker so
tracker is pretty simple call this track
app all you do is just give this a
series of key value pairs to go ahead
and track your deployment or your
application so for example you can do
app equal I don't know test app
okay I don't know what that is out
anyway um so that's pretty much the I
mean you get the point out of that one
cool so going back to our terminal kind
of as one does with anything or
kubernetes related this is actually
going ahead and creating it is moved on
so it is created the Redis application
and now it's running the the node.js
application so to show that in action
because I'm not sure if I want to wait
for it to finish doing its thing
show you what this looks like when it's
deployed let's go out to yield Internet
so one of things we do here is we
actually use let's encrypt to give you a
fully encrypted and end connection to
your application so this is just the
demo app it's just rust and webassembly
and all it kind of does is kind of type
in a sentence and a language and it
tells you what it is so that's pretty
much all of the workflow features that
we've been kind of working on and so
pretty excited for everybody to start
trying this in pre-release so with that
I'm gonna turn it over to Liam to go
talk about sort of all of our data
solutions that powers all of this Thank
You Ike morning everyone my name is
Alain Karim I'm a product manager at net
up I'm a product manager for our cloud
volume service offering so while Matt
and the rest of the kubernetes team have
been busy at work basically deploying
all of the cloud native application
tools that you mentioned we've also been
hard at work basically building out a
cloud native file services offering
that's high performance in partnership
with GCP that service is called cloud
volume service and really i'm gonna talk
about the why first why we did this what
we heard from customers really were two
things
one was that they had existing file
based applications and workloads that
they wanted to move to Google cloud so
they needed posix-compliant file
services in Google cloud but not only
that they needed those those services to
be highly performant and highly
available the second thing we also heard
was for cloud native applications being
able to have storage services that were
very flexible easy to manage and
performant for all of the stuff that
they were doing for persistent
applications in kubernetes was another
gap so with cloud volume service those
are really the two use cases that were
going after solving for customers so
that's a little bit about the why so
let's talk about the what what is cloud
volume service so as I'm
mentioned it's a fully managed cloud
native file services offering that we've
built in partnership with Google cloud
and when I say it's fully managed what
does that mean it means that you as an
application owner or as a developer
simply go into the Google cloud console
or with our beta release using the api's
provision an NFS endpoint that has
capacity and performance characteristics
you don't have to worry about any of the
back-end infrastructure details to
actually deliver that endpoint so
capacity planning networks security all
of that is really managed in the backend
by net app and Google you simply as an
application owner or a developer simply
consume the endpoint with the
performance and capacity that you need
to show the simplicity of this actually
we're running a little short on time so
the the demo is something we're gonna do
at the booth but we're actually running
a fun contest at our booth for people
that have never seen a cloud volume
don't know what a cloud volume is to go
spin one up and I think the current
record is around 18 seconds so in
addition to being super simple to
provision and super simple to consume
cloud volumes provides high availability
within a particular Google region and
there's a set of regions that we're
currently available in but the next big
thing is around performance cloud
volumes enables a set of workloads now
to run Google cloud that was previously
unable to run ever so we're able to
provide hundreds of thousands of I ops
and guarantee those via SL O's at very
very low latency so most of our region's
we deploy the service in sub to
milliseconds you can get for over a
hundred thousand iOS so again this opens
up a whole class of applications that
were previously not able to run on GCP
finally I mentioned this notion of being
built in partnership with Google and
being basically a native service within
GCP what does this mean it means that
customers are able to log in through
their familiar terms with with the cloud
console go into the cloud console
without any other identity or access
management integration from NetApp just
use your standard project and the
credentials that you use to log into
your project discover the cloud volumes
UI or the API enable it and go and
provision your
that means that there's really no
leaving the cloud console so the whole
experience is very very seamless like
any other Google native service we also
integrate with Google service control
for those of you that know that facility
it allows us to push all of our metrics
logs and monitoring data into Google
service control and so you can consume
that data from stackdriver and
essentially monitor what your file
systems are doing in terms of
performance availability and then be
able to even monitor and set alerts from
stackdriver natively like you would do
for any other Google service and then
finally from a support perspective we're
you know this is aimed at enterprise
workloads so support is actually
provided directly by Google Google may
escalate some issues to net up in the
backend but by and large you know you as
a Google customer to deal directly with
Google even though it's an era ended up
service so I could go on and on talking
about the features and what it's doing
but what I really want to do is hear
from someone that's using this and for
that we've actually got Luis virzi from
Cardinal Health they've been using the
service for a while so I'd like to have
him come up and talk about their
experience hi Lim hello everyone just
wanted to talk a little bit about like a
limb said how how we came about our
decision to use net app cloud volume
service and and how our experience has
been so far so we have been spending the
last couple years doing a lift and shift
migration bringing existing applications
out of our data center and into the
cloud we've started with our non prod
dev QA and have since moved on to stage
and prod systems and about a year ago we
switched over to GCP for many technical
and business reasons we really found GCP
was a better cloud platform for what we
needed to provide to our application
teams but as we started moving these
stage and production systems we we
realized that we weren't able to as we
wanted to kind of get away from network
attached storage a lot of the
applications that we had out there some
of them are cots some of them are
homegrown legacy applications they're
built on you
assuming that they had Nazz for high of
it for providing high available
solutions and so we started looking
around for a solution that would give us
the ability to provision quickly on
demand not have to sign a Pio with
another vendor make commitments and
NetApp met all those things for us right
so it's been really easy to provision
that storage and get data out to our
application teams Thanks so could you
maybe give us a few more examples of the
types of applications that you're
running as well as sort of what the ramp
journey looked like sure we started out
obviously with with lower lower
environments our sa p RS ap platform
required a place for for them to do
their to do their deployments through
the environments we started with that we
started with some other low-risk
applications we've since moved on to
production s ap we've got our enterprise
content management that's going to be
going into cloud volumes in production
here shortly it's been in our
performance environment for a little
while so we're gonna have 20-plus
terabytes of our enterprise content
serving up through our e-commerce site
and through our s ap environment that is
going to be running off of NetApp and
what was the last part sort of what has
the journey been like in terms of using
the service it's the journey has been
very easy right so the upfront work is
just getting the networking set up which
with the beta release I think that's
going to be even even easier but that
really the hardest part was spending 30
minutes on a call with it with the net
app engineers to get our networking
connected up after that it literally is
seconds to set up a volume we always
start with their standard tier and if
application teams aren't getting the
performance that they need with a click
of a button they can have twice the AI
ops with another click of the button
they can have four times the AI ops if
they need if they need to grow from two
terabytes to five terabytes it's another
click of a button
no restarts no copying of storage no
expanding arrays no no none of that
complex work that you know system
administrators have had to deal with in
the past so it's really a very easy
solution that we can put in the hands of
our application teams so one of the
things in terms of outcomes right when
you take these applications and move
them to cloud what kind of like
time-based acceleration impact do you
think having this services made in terms
of executing those projects sure if we
had to refactor these applications out
of using network-attached storage it
would have taken months or years or
longer really it would have taken months
per application to get these refactor
and at Cardinal we've got hundreds of
applications that are relying on Nazz
storage so it really saved us years of
effort of having to refactor these
applications and it's something that
application teams can kind of do on
their own time now where they can work
on getting getting their storage into
other formats that that typically in a
datacenter
you don't have access to you so you
already pointed out one of the things
that you don't like which was the
networking stuff that we had to do and
with with cloud it's amazing how much
networking stuff you have to do but what
are some of the other things that you're
basically looking for enhancements
around that we're releasing in the
upcoming release
sure from being in a heavily compliance
regulated marketplace or industry a lot
of our workloads are going to need nfsv4
with encryption obviously you don't want
a half pH I data anywhere that's not
encrypted there are already doing the
encryption at rest but we're looking
forward to being able to do encryption
and transit as well the other thing is
dr that we don't have to think about
right right now we're we're using some
services to sync our data to another
region it would be great if you could
just with a click of a button have that
replication taken care of and then we
wouldn't need to administer that
and the the third thing is access across
V pcs so right now with the the net
green networking setup that we have we
aren't able to access data across our V
pcs but I think there should be some
solutions coming forward that'll solve
that problem for us well thank you very
much Lois so with with that I want to
spend a few minutes talking about what
is coming next many of the things that
Louis mentioned has been you know
feedback that we've gotten from Cardinal
health as well as other customers so
with the beta release that we're
planning for the end of May essentially
we're gonna automate the whole
networking flow that Louis talked about
give users a lot more control in terms
of which VP sees which shared VP sees
have access to the service and how they
govern permissions within their
organizations and their service projects
to get access to these data services if
you've got service projects gke clusters
that are in those service projects you
can actually have much more granular
connectivity into these data services
we're also going to be rolling out
Trident which is an existing plugin that
we have that will automate the creation
of persistent volumes and precision
volume claims when you're running
stateful applications that'll
automatically provision cloud volumes in
the backend and connect those to your
kubernetes environments and obviously
we're going to be adding more regions
here in the US in Europe as well so
before we get into sort of the questions
I just wanted to sort of give the
audience you know please join our
pre-release programs a lot of these are
driven by obviously conversations and
feedback that we get from customers but
joining these pre-release programs
allows you to provide feedback and
really shape how we do these products
engage with us on Twitter those are the
names up there please visit us in the
booth as well we've got most of these
demos and a bunch of subject matter
experts there that can walk you through
the stuff we talked about as was
mentioned earlier the Nvidia demo is
coming up at noon so right around noon
so that'll be another cool one to see so
that's about all the content we had we
want to leave a little bit of time at
the end for Q&A as well and I'll bring
Matt and the rest of the speakers up for
questions
[Music]